東校拒否の子供がうちで立ち直ってあろう
ことかサンフランシスコから神戸泊があっ
たからねそこまでの1人のりのヨット
レースでクラス優勝したんやでテレビが
呼んでななんであなたはそういうことが
できるのか言って言ってきたそれ決まっ
とるやないかあ教育が間違って俺が正しい
教育をするからそういう結果が起こるんや
ないか言たその視界をやっとったのが哲学
の先生よそれで怒り出してなふざけるなと
か言お前ごにどうのが見に来い見に来たら
分かるその代わり必ず2回来いよでもう
最初に入ってきた時にできるだけ間もい
やつを見ろとそれが2ヶ月後にどういう風
になっとるか見ろとそうしたら分かる言っ
たって私のものそんなもの見る必要がない
とか見たってだめだとか現場が怖いからね
あいつらえ言っとったけど分かった行って
やるっていうこら言ってやるとはなんや
見せてやると言っとるんやありがたく見せ
てもらえまふとふれ言ってねこれが哲学の
教授
やれでやってきたんやってきたらねさあ今
から出るぞ言って船を出そうとしたらコチ
の諸君集まってくださいとか言ってコチ
集めちも出れへんやないかコチがおらん
とこに出すわけにいかんからなましがない
行ったれ言うてしたら俺も行こうとしたら
お前は来るなっていうでコーチを集めて
言ったことが君たちはなぜあんな
ヒットラーみたいな男に従っているんだ
っていう言い方をしてあれは鬼やぞ悪魔だ
ぞそしたら中の高知の1人がね校長言って
呼んどるんやうんどうした言うたらこの
バカがね校長のこと悪魔って言ってますよ
それでええんや本当の悪魔はそっちや俺は
神みたいなもんな悪魔から見たら神は悪魔
やろ俺を向かって悪魔というのはそいつが
悪魔の証拠やそみんなうえ言って手叩いて
喜んでさあやろやろ言ってこら邪魔するな
言ってねみんな出ていっ
てでその時に入ったばっかりのやつが1人
よってねこれが脳性症に麻痺ない足がこう
うまく歩けるのでそれが入ったばっかりで
ただね頭は正常だもんで裏返しのことを
やるわけね大学もちゃんと卒業して結構
いい成績で卒業しとるだけど人の目に動け
その苛立ちがあってね偉そうな口聞くもん
でどこへ行ったて就職できへん跳ねられ
ちまうやと親が会社をやっとってな社長
なんやもうしょうがないから言って自分の
とこに入れたそしたら入った初日にね全
従業員集まれ言ってそいつが言い出したで
自分はあの高いところに立って従業員全部
集まってその前でな君たちは生ぜ高校卒な
んだから分からないだろうけども人生と
いうものは君たちの思ってるようなもん
じゃないなんて言い出してそうしたら
みんながね現場の人間やからねふざけるな
言うことやで全員自費出してあんなやが
将来社長になったらか会社潰れるから今の
うちにもうやめる言ってれで親父が怒って
な元スモー部のキャプテンやっとった腕に
自信があるもんでなそいつをボコボコにし
てね殺しかけて救急車やってきたっていう
んやからほれでその染まって全員標撤回し
てそのまま存続したんやけど行くとまた
同じようなことやろうとするんまた
ひっぱたく殺す半殺しにするんよお母さん
と姉ちゃんがおってこのままだとあれ殺し
ちゃうだから今のうちにもうなんとか
しようということになってうちに入れたん
やそいつが入ったばかりでバカみたいな口
世の中渡ってきたやつやもんでなその哲学
のバカに向かってバカ同士の話やからな私
を取ってくれっていうわけテレビに映り
たくてしょうがないそういうタイプのやつ
はなご覧の通り私は脳性小に麻痺で足が
悪いうまく動かんこっから逃げたいんだ
けど逃げられない唯一逃げる方法は自殺を
して死ぬことなんだって言って分かった
ようなこと言ってそれを取っていってね次
のテレビの時でこんなこと言っとるやない
か言ってそのバカが言うんや2回目はもう
こうへんのだ約束高いでなそいつがよもう
ようなっちまっとるもんで来たらもう
いっぺん出さしたろう思って待ち構えとっ
たけどなんやか言ってこうへんねで一応来
てくれ言て今度呼ばたれで言ってそれを
言ったったやあんたなんで2回目コやった
やこの前あんたが言ったあの男もうすげえ
よなっとるで素直になっとるしあれやっ
たら就職
できる人間はパンの身にて生きるものに
あらずなんていうあのバカなキリスト教の
バカよあれだってちの人生を生きるあれが
あって自分の精神に従ってどうなこうなな
て言い出して心のそっから馬鹿にしてやる
言ってなその教授をやっつけて何にもでき
んお前は哲学の教授人にどんな影響も
与えれんそれが偉そうなことを言うから
哲学が馬鹿にされるんや俺もバカにしとる
とどうしろと言うんだよまこんな番組やめ
ちまえてお前が出るからいかんのやもっと
いい番組にすることができるやろうしたら
真夜中やで電話が成りだしてないで俺が出
たら講義の電話が来ると思っとったもんで
電話交換しような普段1人なのにに5人
ぐらい用意しとってそれがみんな
じゃんじゃんなって電話聞いとるんやで
合計ね200何本かかってきたっていうで
そいつに対して教授は大喜びを全部俺の
味方に決まっとる思っとるそうかその結果
はどうだったんだねあの教授が可いそうだ
というのがありましたよあそうかどれ
ぐらい1つあの200なと全てあの教授を
やめさせろという電話でし
た結局ね現実のないやつ実際ののないやつ
現場のないやついうこと聞いたらいかんね
嘘ばっかり言っとに決まっとるに自分の頭
の中で自分を正当化する方法を考えてで
言っとるに過ぎにリベラルってみんなそう
やろ自分でリベラル試したことも何にも
ないやろ特に教育に試したら子供がダメに
なっちまうんだからそういう風に彼らの
1番の血管は精神とは何かを知らんことや
あいつらやっつける最後の手段やま精神の
定義してみいよできへんやろとは何かも
知らずに精神について語るのかえ大体その
辺でみんな黙るわね